[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROBERT SAXBY: Hi.
Good afternoon.
I'm Robert.
I'm a big data specialist
based out of Amsterdam.
I'm here today
together with Ashok.
He's from the Bay Area.
ASHOK HOLLA: Hello.
ROBERT SAXBY: A
customer engineer
working in the Bay Area.
So we're going to take you
today through migrating
data warehouses.
If you have a
question that really
can't wait until the end,
just put up your hand.
There's going to be quite--
we're going to do this
in three sections.
So the first 10,
15 minutes, we're
going to go through a
little bit of the reasoning
why, then we're going to look
at some reference architectures.
After we've done
that, we will move
on to a demo for
about 20 minutes
and actually look at some
of the work involved.
And then we will come on
to the more, let's say,
the logistics of it.
So we can go through
the technology.
But after that, what
does it actually
look like to actually get all
the parties involved actually
committed and working towards
the goal of this data warehouse
migration?
So to start us off,
let's have a little think
about a data warehouse
and what it actually is.
So often, when we're talking
about data warehouses, when
I'm working with
customers-- and I
should say previous to
joining Google myself,
I was a customer.
I worked for a company
as a lead data engineer.
And I moved a data
warehouse to BigQuery.
So I have some
hands on experience
with the stuff as well.
And when we were doing that,
often when I was talking
to some of the people
in the business,
the use case that was presented
was the data warehouse.
Well, the data warehouse
isn't a use case.
It's something that
enables use cases.
So it's the underlying platform.
And that was really key
to get in everyone's minds
to say, look, you know, there's
a reason why we're doing this.
And let's understand what that
reason is, because then we
can actually think about
what we want to do,
because there might be some
stuff we want to migrate.
There might be some
workloads that we no longer
want to take with us.
But what are the use cases
we're trying to fulfill?
Now, we tried to split this
up into four different types
of use case.
I'm going to walk
through them now.
So here they all are--
operational reporting, ad hoc
reporting, ad hoc analysis,
and operationalized insight.
So we'll take you
through one by one.
So the first one,
operational reporting--
this is the common,
typical dashboarding area.
So I'm in the business,
and I want a dashboard
to actually see how much
inventory do I have left,
how are the sales doing this
month, the queries get built,
the dashboard gets put in place.
So what are some of
the concerns that we
might want to think
about if we're
going to migrate some
of these workloads,
or what are some of the concerns
that are typically associated
with this particular use case?
Well, one is obviously
data quality.
If the data quality is not
good, those numbers aren't good.
Data timeliness--
that's a big thing.
Often when you're working
on premise with your data
warehouse team, especially if
you're coming from, let's say,
more legacy setup, there's
a lot of batch processes
that run at night.
If one of those batch
processes fails,
then the question
is, is everything
going to be there in time to
get the numbers up the next day?
I've heard that question
so many times in the past.
And then reliability--
which obviously comes
into the other two as well.
But if you don't have good
reliability with your system,
then you're trying to--
the other two are very difficult
to deliver on, let's say.
So next one is ad hoc reporting.
So typically, with the
operational reporting,
that is the thing that everyone
says, I want those numbers.
I want those
dashboards available.
If they're not
there, you probably
have some measurements
and metrics around there,
some SLOs that
you're trying to say
these dashboards are going to
be ready, available for everyone
to use.
The ad hoc reporting
sometimes suffers
because it's resource bound.
You have a certain
number of resources
that you're using to
do all your processing.
And then when it comes to the
actual ad hoc reporting piece,
there are people
that have ideas.
They want to try and
start looking at things.
They're using visualization
tools and this kind of stuff.
Essentially what they
need is more data.
They need visualization
tools, and they need access
to historical data.
So all of this requires
we have enough storage
to store the data, we
have enough capacity
to run those kind of
processing, and we
can support all the
different types of tools
that they want to use.
So the next one is
ad hoc analysis.
This is the data science
area, the statistical area
where people are
actually going in there.
They're trying to work out
what's this new trend, what's
this thing that I'm looking at.
Why have I got some
country, for example, that's
underperforming in sales?
It's been doing
well all the time,
and now suddenly
it's underperforming.
What caused that?
And again, what we need
here is strong tools
to be able to do this.
Again, capacity comes up.
If you don't have the capacity,
then these types of questions
sometimes get put
in second place
because the other things
have been prioritized.
And the last one,
operational insight--
this is operationalized
insight, I should say.
I knew it was going to
be a tongue twister.
This is really where
everyone wants to be.
This is the place where,
essentially, you've
done all this analysis
work, and you're
using it to predict the future.
So you're using it to work
out, for example here, I'm
trying to work out
how much fuel I need
or how much I should purchase
for the next quarter.
I'm using these numbers to
actually drive those decisions.
So this is a decision
making space.
Again, some of the
challenges in this area--
predictive capabilities,
like, what kind
of tools, what
kind of frameworks
do you want to support,
diverse data sources, again,
data coming from all
different places.
Some of it can be stored
easily in the data warehouse.
Some of it's in the
data lake or may
be not even
available, and again,
having enough capacity
to run this stuff.
So I'm going to make some
very gross generalizations.
But what we see
when we're working
with customers--
and again, these
are generalizations, so they
might not be specific to you.
But some of the stuff
that we see, for example,
is that a lot of
work is being done.
And a lot of people start from
the operational reporting side.
And they want to move to
that operationalized insight.
But there's a lot
of stuff that has
to be done to get them there.
And they don't want to
sacrifice all the work
that they've done to have their
operational reporting in place.
So if we're going to
migrate the data warehouse,
we can say, oh, great,
now we can do this--
we can run some machine
learning models.
And we can take that output
and we can make it available
so we can do some kind
of recommendation system,
for example.
But if they can't support
the reports and the dashboard
that they've been relying
on, then they're like, well,
first we need to solve that.
That's what we see
coming time and again.
And we see often a
lot of customers,
when they're working with
their stuff on premise,
they struggle for resources.
There's a finite number of
resources that they have.
And those resources are--
there's a lot of claim
on those resources.
So there's a good reason for
them to move to the cloud,
because we can give them more
and more resources to use.
We don't have those
same constraints.
But yeah, hopefully that gives
some indication the reasons
why we would do this.
So as another kind
of generalization,
this is the kind
of movement we see.
We see people starting
with operational reporting,
with ad hoc reporting,
and moving up
into that
operationalized insight.
And of course, a lot of
that operationalized insight
is based off that ad
hoc analysis as well,
building out those
machine learning
models or other prediction
models to actually take you
to that place
where you can start
putting this into
some kind of process
to actually make decisions.
So obviously, no slide deck
is complete without Maslow's
pyramid.
So here's a best attempt
at something very colorful.
What we've basically got here
is, if you look at each level,
to get to that top piece,
this is the kind of stuff
that is built on.
So we've got data quality,
data timing that's
right there at the bottom.
We've got the capacity
and the tooling.
You need all of
these things to be
able to fulfill your
different use cases.
So this is what your
platform should be providing.
OK.
So why do people--
well, why do folks actually
consider migrating their data
warehouse in the first place?
Well, obviously, I've just
been through some of them,
but just to kind of recap
cost of infrastructure,
not having enough resources.
Another one that we see is
there are specific skill sets
that you need to run
some of these systems.
So for example, let's say
you're running Hive on Hadoop.
You might have a
whole team that's
actually required just to
support that Hive installation.
And that might not be
core to their business.
So you're thinking,
hang on, I don't
mind having one or two
people doing this but having
a whole team.
I could have that team
doing something else.
So these are things
to think about.
And some of the stuff
that kind of limits
there as well are
things like upgrades.
So I'm sure some of you went
to the Dataproc talk yesterday.
And you would have
seen, for example,
it's very easy in
the cloud to run
different versions of Hadoop,
whereas when you are on premise
and you need to update because
you're missing some capability,
that might mean shutting
off the cluster,
actually performing the update,
and if it doesn't go well
rolling back.
So you have this
game that you have
to play to actually give that
capability that you're trying
to offer to your end users.
And concurrency often
suffers as well.
A lot of these systems
have the performance
that you require to
actually run the query,
but when it comes to many
users asking questions
at the same time, there is some
trade off in concurrency there.
So Google Cloud's
data warehouse.
I'm just going to
take a sip of water.
That's always good for YouTube.
So Google Cloud's
data warehouse.
Well, BigQuery, as
you know, that's
why you're here, obviously.
I probably don't
need to tell you
any of these things, because
you've probably already
been looking at BigQuery
and you're thinking,
yeah, that's great.
I know BigQuery.
But just for anyone
that hasn't seen it,
these are some of the
things that we call out
on BigQuery for the reasons why
customers are going to move.
Later I'll look at some
of the new features that
have been mentioned today.
But some of the
important ones here,
and I think the most crucial--
when you're migrating a data
warehouse, it's like can
I use the skills I already
have, so the standard SQL.
That's a hugely important one.
Can it cope with the amount
of data and the concurrency
that I need to actually get
the benefits that everyone's
able to perform their analysis?
I can run all these
different types of reports.
And you know, security
here, so the encryption--
we have default encryption
on all of our storage.
You can choose to bring
your own encryption keys.
So for particularly
sensitive workloads,
managing your own
encryption keys
might be a good thing
for you to be able to do.
That's particularly important
in something like the finance
sector with certain data, and
then highly available, managed.
You don't have to focus on
the operation of BigQuery.
You can actually focus on using
BigQuery and actually creating
your use cases.
So very high level
architecture--
this is what
BigQuery looks like.
There are a number of parts, but
I will try and break it down.
So storage is
separated from compute.
This is common across
all of Google products.
We'll see it a little
bit more in a moment.
That petabyte network
in between-- it's
actually 1.3 petabytes.
That's something like
130,000 machines talking
at 10 gigabits per second.
What that essentially
means is that we
can have our compute
disaggregated from our storage.
We can grow either
one independently.
We can serve multiple queries
from the same storage.
For example, if you were
trying to create your own data
warehouse using Hive and
Parquet and Hadoop, for example,
you would have to
make some choices
as you grow that cluster.
There is a ratio
of CPU and memory
that you attach to those disks
that you're making available.
And obviously you can optimize.
You can say I'm going to have
bigger disks and fewer CPUs,
or the other way around, but you
still need to think about that.
They're not separate.
Here they are.
And that's really
possible because
of the network in between
and how fast that is.
Other things which
are very important
here is that we have, on the
right-hand side, standard SQL,
so everyone can use a language
which is common to them.
And on the left hand
side, we support
both batch and streaming data.
So you can have a table
with like a petabyte of data
in that table and you
can still be streaming
in the latest updates.
And you can query over both
of those in the same query.
So you can have a query which
is basically running and giving
you the context between
what's happening now
and the historical data
from running a SQL query.
So this is not unique to
BigQuery, that separation.
This is across all
of our products.
So if you look at
the bottom here,
these are all the
different types of storage.
I have a storage
session this afternoon
if you want to know
more about that.
But the different
types of storage--
I'll call a few out here.
So BigQuery is columnar storage.
So Dremel is the
original white paper.
We now call it Capacitor.
It's like an
evolution from there.
To give you an idea,
storage formats like Parquet
are actually based
off of Dremel.
So Bigtable-- it's key
value is column family.
It's really good for
random reads and writes.
Sometimes you might want
to query that with SQL.
Well, that's possible through
BigQuery doing federation.
You can also-- let's
say you had a data lake
and you've got Avro files,
CSV files, ORC files,
Parquet files,
JSON files, and you
don't want to load those yet
into BigQuery for some reason.
You can have them available
on Google Cloud Storage.
And you can run federated
queries over them as well.
So some of them you can do
federating queries and others
you have to load for a job.
But CSV, Avro, and JSON all
support the federated query
model.
So you have different options
available to you here.
I mean, obviously if you want to
get the best native performance
of BigQuery, then
the columnar storage
is obviously suited for
running analytical queries.
That's why that storage exists.
But this gives you an idea.
And the same data that
you're storing in BigQuery
maybe you need to make available
to your machine learning
algorithms for training.
So you'd have at the top
there Cloud ML Engine, which
can access BigQuery and actually
pull from that data storage
to actually go and
train this model.
So it's really about thinking
about which storage fits
and what type of
processing fits.
So on the top, if it's
BigQuery, it's SQL.
On the bottom, if it's
BigQuery, it's columnar storage.
On the bottom, if you have a
random read/write use case,
you would think about
something like Bigtable.
If you wanted to run some
federated ad hoc queries
with that, you
could use BigQuery.
If you wanted to have
the columnar performance,
then you would use
something like Dataflow
to take that BigQuery data--
that Bigtable data, sorry--
and load it into BigQuery
so you get a benefit
from the high performance.
And if you need both
types of access,
so the high
analytical performance
and the random read/write
stuff, use two types of storage.
Just make sure the
pipelines feeding
that are idempotent
functional so
that you can reload it and
have a consistent output.
We will look a little bit about
that in the demo in a moment.
So moving on here, this
is one of our customers.
I'll let you read
this yourselves.
But this is basically-- well,
let me bring up the bigger one.
The reason for
doing this together
with us is that we work
on providing a system
managed service and you
work on your use cases.
The more we can
do that, the more
we can have a successful
partnership together.
But we have our engineering
focus on bringing capabilities,
and you have your
engineering focused
on using those capabilities
to do cool stuff with it.
So I'm going to move very
quickly through the reference
architectures.
This first reference
architecture--
let me get back a slide.
This is like, OK, I'm going
to do a migration now.
Where do I start?
So obviously you
don't jump and say,
click your fingers and
the migration is done.
Migrations are complex.
This is the first set up
that we'd like to advocate.
So on the left hand side, we've
basically got your current
on prem situation.
This may look like what
you're running on prem.
It may not.
But to give you
some idea, this is
kind of like-- you have
your source systems,
you have some kind
of ETL process
which loads that
data into staging,
runs, does some transmitter
maybe denormalization,
dimensionalizes
that data, makes it
available in a data warehouse.
And there's a whole bunch
of reports and use cases
that are taking advantage
of that data there.
And the orchestration piece
in the middle that's basically
allowing you to do all
of that, making sure
that happens every
day, making sure things
happen in the right order.
So in the first move
that we're going
to look at in the demo at the
moment is actually a mirroring.
So we will read from the
current data warehouse.
And our goal will be
in the first instance
is to have the same
available in BigQuery.
Once that's available
in BigQuery,
you can start denormalizing
some of that data,
aggregating some
of the data to make
it available for use cases.
So for new reporting use cases.
We're going to use
data studio here,
but there's a whole bunch of
tools out there from partners
that you can use for the
reporting as for the ETL
as well, but we'll come
onto that in a moment.
So the piece that we're
going to look at here
is what do we need to do to
be able to mirror the data
warehouse onto BigQuery.
And to recap why
are we doing this,
we want to get results fast.
We want to have the least
amount of risk to our business.
We're selling them
on quite a big thing.
So we don't want to say,
look, go ahead and do this,
and then once you've done it,
we will see how long it takes.
No.
Let's take a route where
we can do some of this,
show them how good
it works for them,
show them what
they get out of it.
You know, don't put their
current processing at risk.
And once that works, then we
can move onto the next phase.
And we also get GCP adoption.
You know, there are
many people that
haven't used all
the GCP tools, maybe
in your business, other
developers, other analysts,
other business users.
And they get from
this the opportunity
to start working
with those tools.
And importantly, we
can benchmark stuff.
Numbers talk.
So we can actually show to
any of our stakeholders, look,
you know, we were running
these queries here before.
It was taking this much.
We had this kind of concurrency.
We could only support
this number of users.
And now we can do this.
So you get that from
this first architecture.
What's the target?
Well, we don't want to go from
running one data warehouse
to running two data warehouses.
The whole idea is to
do this migration.
So the target is obviously to
actually have the full data
warehouse process running on GCP
and reading from those sources.
Now those sources
might be on GCP.
They might be on prem.
They could be on
another cloud provider.
But essentially for this
particular migration,
what we're looking at
is taking that data
from wherever those sources may
be and doing the ETL process,
doing the data warehouse
process on Google Cloud.
And that's what
we're going to look
at in the demo, so both stages.
So with that I'm
going to hand over
to Ashok for the demo section.
ASHOK HOLLA: Thanks, Rob.
All right, let's get into it.
So today we'll look
at what it takes
to do the migration to GCP.
And in this first stage, we look
at mirroring the data warehouse
to BigQuery.
And we'll start with
the data already landed
in Google Cloud Storage.
So I'll be doing a lot of
back and forth switching
because of the slides and demo.
OK.
So what we've done is we
are mirroring on prem data
warehouse, right, so we already
have the facts and dimension
data.
And since facts are
usually larger in size,
we have to organize
them by date.
And let's take a look
at the fact data here.
So they are organized by date.
And if something goes
wrong or you update your
on prem data warehouse,
all you do is just reload
the partition, right?
And in BigQuery we
are going to store
this as a partitioned table.
And dimensions
are usually small.
So you don't really
have to partition them.
And it's OK to basically
refresh all the dimension
data every day.
And this also ensures that
any slowly changing dimension
techniques that you have
implied would just carry over
to the data warehouse as well.
And this is how the dimension
data looks for the demo.
And for the demo I'm
using TPC-DS data just
to get a data warehouse set up.
So one second.
I need to get a hang
of the switching here.
OK.
So we looked at the data sets.
So what we are doing
is we are going
to stage the data in Google
Cloud Storage, facts organized
by date and dimensions
in just a folder.
And we are going to do
a refresh every day.
And then we are going to use
Cloud Composer to basically
orchestrate this workflow
and materialize the table
in the BigQuery data format.
Once that is done,
what we'll do is
we'll run some downstream
aggregation queries.
We can materialise that as well.
And it's always a good practice
to materialize any aggregation
queries that are frequently used
so that your reports are not
lagging due to
runtime calculations
and also the data is not
open for interpretation.
All right, so let's
take a look at that.
OK.
So what we are trying
to do is we're trying
to get to this report, right?
So this report is
basically calculating
cumulative sales and
returns, both sales channel.
And below we are seeing a
scatterplot of net sales
by different channels.
So how do we get there?
So as I said, we are using
Cloud Composer to basically
orchestrate this workflow.
So what we are seeing
here is, on the left,
we are creating staging tables.
So we are basically creating a
federated BigQuery table which
is pointing to a file
in Google Cloud Storage,
and then we materialized that
into a native BigQuery table.
And once that is done, we do
the same thing with fact tables.
But it may so happen
that I know you probably
have to replay a
partition because you've
updated something on prem.
So you have to replay the
partition for your fact data.
So what we have
done is basically
we have added a Boolean
variable in the airflow code
to basically just load fact
data and not dimension data.
So in this way you have a
repeatable idempotent process
for loading fact data.
And this is a code
that does just that.
Right.
So all I'm doing is this is
an airflow variable which
I have defined up here.
And then if it is yes, then
we load dimension and staging.
If it is no, we just
lost the dimension.
All right.
So let me just trigger
this and then I'll
walk you through the
individual processes.
So I'm going to
trigger it for today.
So let's just quickly check if
the variable is set for today.
It is yes, 25.
So I'm going to go back
and trigger the table--
trigger the DAG.
All right.
So it is running.
So let's just go back there.
OK.
So I spoke about
external tables being
used for staging purpose
and Google Cloud Storage
being the staging area.
Let's take a look at
the definition of those.
So the dimensions table, as
I said, is refreshed daily.
So it's just pointing to
a location in Google Cloud
Storage without any
database partitions.
And the fact tables are
partitioned by date,
hence they are stored
in a date folder.
So it is today, right?
And for materializing those
tables from the staging area
into BigQuery native,
all we are doing
is just a simple
select star a table.
Well, then you could
obviously get creative
and then add your
own transformations
or do further
denormalization if needed.
The aggregation
query that I'm using
is a simple query that
aggregates all the sales
and returns by three different
channels, their sales--
the store, web, and
catalog channels.
And I'm just doing a
cumulative sales and returns.
Just a summation on all
the three up to today.
Let's take a look at the
DAG if it's finished.
That's still running.
We'll give it a minute.
OK.
So as you can see, the staging
areas have been created.
And then they have
been materialized.
Now we are at a
stage where we're
trying to materialize fact.
That is done as well.
So it's success.
Now it's the last stage
where we are materializing
the aggregation query as well.
So once this is done,
we should be able to--
we should be able to see
a partition in the sales
by channel table, which I
created for materializing
the ideation query.
And this is done as well.
Let's take a look
at the partition.
So I'm querying the
partition summary metadata
for that particular table.
And if I run this query, I
should see a partition here.
So as you can see--
so 425, which was
created just now.
Now, if I go to the
report, I should
be able to see the report
being updated for today.
There you go.
So that's demo one
where we mirrored the
on prem data warehouse
to Google Cloud Storage.
Now let's take a look--
I need to switch.
Oops.
Sorry.
Sorry about that.
OK.
So let's take a look
at demo two wherein we
have done the cut off, right?
So the end state is we
are running the data
warehouse in Google
Cloud Storage
and what does it take
to make that functional.
OK.
So this workflow looks quite
similar to what we had earlier.
But there's a
significant difference.
We are partitioning
dimensions as well.
Now it's obvious why
we partition facts,
because they're larger.
And I've spoken about that.
But why dimensions?
Number one, to keep the whole
workflow simple and easy
to maintain.
And we have a reproducible
and idempotent process as far
as data pipeline is concerned.
And also because NCDs
are cumbersome, right?
Slowly changing
dimensions are cumbersome
and can get easily complicated.
With this, what you
can do is you're
just doing a refresh off
your everyday dimension data
into a new partition
in BigQuery.
This gives you
bitemporality, another easy
to implement bitemporality.
You can go back in time and
look at the state of your data
at that point in time by just
querying a particular partition
and dimension.
So you don't have to
create complex joins,
or you don't have to have
complex ETL processes
to maintain.
So that's why we are
partitioning dimension data
as well.
So this is part of the
functional data engineering
approach which we
have taken here.
The fact data is
partitioned by event date,
and the dimensioned data is
partitioned by the processing
date when you processed this.
OK.
So I'm going to switch back
here and go to my second demo.
So I said that dimension and
fact are both partitioned
once you do a cut off.
Let's take a look at
the dimension data.
So it is, in fact,
partitioned by date.
Let's take a look
at the DAG that
supports this whole workflow.
So it's similar to the
one that we had earlier.
We are integrating
staging tables,
integrating a federated table
in BigQuery for both domination
and fact.
We are materializing
dimension data.
So note that we are
using TPC-E certification
data, which is in normal form.
So obviously we have to create
facts and dimensioned data when
we materialize in BigQuery.
So this task is doing just that.
It is materializing
the dimensioned data.
Once that is done, we are going
to materialize the fact data.
And that will be the
end of this workflow.
So let me just trigger
this and then walk you
through the whole process.
OK.
So that's triggered.
Now let's take a look
at the various queries.
So I said that the dimension
and fact tables are both
organized by date.
So this is a fact table thread.
It's organized by date.
And let's take a look at
the company table, which
is the dimensioned data.
It's also organized by
date in the staging area.
And the queries that
I'm using to materialize
these tables into BigQuery
are simple joints.
So basically I'm
denormalizing the data.
This is for trade.
And I'm basically joining that
with status type and trade
type.
And for company, I'm
basically joining that
with status type and address.
So you could actually
use any ETL tool
of your choice to do this.
But in this case, I'm just
using SQL and the staging area
being Google Cloud storage.
But one thing to note is
that for a company, which
is a dimension
table, we are having
a partition date, which is
called the create a date here.
And you're partitioning
based on that date, which
is the day when you
run the workflow.
And for trade, which
is a fact data,
we are basically partitioning
by the event date, which
is [INAUDIBLE] in this example.
Let's also take a look
at one of the queries
that we'll be running
after the DAG completes.
So in the previous example,
we saw how we could create
and how we could
materialize a query
and then create a
report on top of it.
But BigQuery can also be
used for ad hoc analysis.
And this query is
basically calculating
the 60-second simple moving
average on bid prices
in a three-hour period
for all the securities
that just get loaded
once the DAG completes.
Let's take a look at the
DAG if it is completed.
It's running.
It'll be done soon.
OK.
So the materialization of
dimensions is complete.
Now the next stage is basically
materialization of the fact
table, which is straight.
And once that is done, we'll
run our moving average query.
It's running.
It'll happen.
So what I'm doing here
is I'm deleting-- so
basically, we are creating
a staging table, right?
So the files are in
Google Cloud Storage
and they are creating
a federated table.
So obviously every
day when you run,
you have to point that table to
the right in a file in Google
Cloud Storage.
So hence the first step is
to basically delete the table
definition and then recreate
it with the file for that date.
So that is what this stage does.
So now the create
stage table is done.
It's a success.
Now, finally, what
we're doing is
we are going to run the
query that I showed earlier,
the denormalization query which
joins trade table with address
and status type and then creates
the fact table in BigQuery.
It should be done in
a few seconds here.
And that's done.
So let's go and
run our query here
for today, which is a moving
average, a 60-second moving
average over a three-hour
period for all the securities.
And there you go.
So it just ran.
And we have all
the moving average.
So BigQuery can be used for
ad hoc analysis as well.
And that completes the end to
end workflow, so for when you--
when you do a complete cut off.
Now let's look at another
interesting concept
in BigQuery.
So far we've seen a functional
data engineering approach
where we create a repeatable
and idempotent processes.
And we basically
replay the workflow
and then update the partitions.
Right?
So we don't do any
DML statements.
But DMLs can be friendly
when used in the right format
and the right way.
And when you do a
DML update, and you
update large chunk of data in
BigQuery, but what if something
goes wrong?
So how do you recover from it.
So we're going to take a
look at that exactly now.
So what I'm showing
here is a query
that basically creates the
trade table that we just loaded
and for a particular
customer ID 472.
So let's take a look as to
what the data looks like.
Now, let's say that I
want to update this trade
table for this
particular customer
for a particular security.
But what I did instead is I
updated the commission column
for all the rows for
that particular customer.
So that's obviously an error.
So I realized that
I made a mistake.
So how do I recover from this?
So there two options, ideally.
The first option
is go back in time.
All you have to
do is just replay
your workflow with
your partition date
equals 22, in this case.
Right.
So July 22.
And then you just
override the partition
and then move on
from there, or you
could use BigQuery snapshots.
Right.
So BigQuery snapshots
are automatically
created and maintained
for you for seven days.
And then you can go
back in time and then
get the state of your table
at that point in time.
So we only use BigQuery
snapshots and DML
to recover from this error.
But before we do
that, let's take
a look at what the status of
the table is after the update.
So what I did is I updated
the commission column
with equals $245
for all the rows
for that particular customer.
So this is how it looks like.
Let's look at the
BigQuery snapshot,
so how it was five minutes
ago before I did my update.
So as you can see,
those securities
have the right
commission values.
Now we're going to use that and
create a temporary table, which
we are going to then use
and do an update join
on the tray table that
we erroneously updated.
So the temporary
table is created.
Now I'm going to
run an update join
with the temporary table and my
trade table for the partition
that I just messed up.
OK.
So that's done.
So what it did is it basically
updated all my customer
rows for customer equals
472 from my new BigQuery
snapshot, the temporary table
that I just created from it.
Let's take a look
at how the data
looks like after correction.
So it should be similar to
what we looked in the BigQuery
snapshot and it is.
It is now at $45.
Now we can just go back
and update for the security
that we really
intended to update.
That's done.
And then we'll just see
how it looks like once
it's updated So all good.
So there are no backlashes.
Right.
So that's the end of the demo.
Before I hand it
off to Robert, I'm
going to quickly talk
about various ways
to ingest data into GCP.
So we have looked at and are
using Google Cloud Storage
as the staging area.
So you can use GS Util and
the storage transfer service
or the data transfer
service that
comes native to Google to
ingest your data to GCP.
But there are a plethora
of partner products
as well which you can use.
And you might already
be using these today
in your existing toolkit.
And it's an easy switch
to basically migrate
data from your on prem
systems or your source systems
into GCP.
Robert, you're up.
ROBERT SAXBY: Thank you, Ashok.
So hopefully that showed you how
easy some of this stuff can be.
I mean we saw two approaches.
We saw the functional
engineering approach,
overwriting partitions,
keeping things
idempotent or repeatable.
And as Ashok demonstrated
in the last piece,
if you do have DML statements
that you're going to run over
multiple days over
a very large table,
you have the BigQuery basically
time travel functionality
for the last seven days to
actually go back and restore.
So that will hopefully help
you in some of this work
that you're going to do.
And again, BigQuery is--
it's the crown jewels
of our data products.
And it really sits there in
the middle in a huge ecosystem.
And these are some of the
partners for the integration.
There's a whole
bunch of partners
as well for reporting
and everything else.
So it's really depending on
how you want to approach this,
you're in good hands.
So let me just, for
anyone that missed
any of these things,
some of the new product
features, you saw
throughout this demo today
the new BigQuery UI.
You can already go and use that.
So for those of you
who are saying, hey,
the BigQuery UI looks different.
What's this new thing up here?
This is not BigQuery.
That's the new UI.
This morning you
heard about BQ ML.
So these are other
things that you
can start to do once you're
operating in BigQuery.
We got partitioning
at the moment.
So you can do partitioning
on like the insertion date
or you can choose
your own date column
as we saw here with
two different examples
of partitioning.
We saw an example
where we were actually
partitioning on a logical date.
Because for our fact
table, that fact data,
we expect it to be
quite large, and we just
want to have the
ability to replay
the events or the
transactions for a given day.
And in the second use case
with the dimension data,
even if your dimension
data is millions of rows,
if you think about that
in context of BigQuery
and these systems
that you can use,
just replaying that again and
having a new snapshot each day
really helps you overcome
some of those slowly changing
dimension property so you have
a different-- the partitioning
we're using there was
basically on a date, which
is the insertion date.
Well, available now
is clustering in beta.
So if you can
imagine clustering,
basically you partition
first on date,
and then you would
have some other column
with a high cardinality which
you basically cluster on.
So again, we're reducing
the amount of data
that we need to pick up
in the initial scan, which
is going to make the query
cheaper to run, faster to run.
So if you have good use cases
for this-- so think about,
first of all, you're
joining or filtering by date
and then you're joining or
filtering by something else.
This would be a good--
yeah.
How do I say feature to
actually go and explore.
Something we didn't show here,
but Data Studio Explorer.
It's basically from
going from BigQuery
and clicking and actually
being able to see
the results of that query
directly in Data Studio.
There are deeper
integrations with Sheets,
so just making the whole
experience using your datas
in BigQuery available
for end users who
are using Google Sheets.
And later this
afternoon at 3:15,
if you're not coming to
my storage talk obviously,
then there's a nice
talk about GSI data
as well, which is amazing.
Some really great demos
to go and see there.
I'm really excited about that.
Actually, I might
just miss my own talk
and go and watch that one.
So we've gone through
quite a lot today.
But what I want to
hand us off is--
so we've gone through some
of the reasons why and what
we can do with this.
We've gone through
an approach, how
we could do that, first
the mirroring and then
the full process running on GCP.
And this last part
is really kind
of like, OK, this is all great,
but how do I organize myself
together with Google and
together with partners
to actually go and
do this migration?
So we put together
a playbook which
we think would help
illustrate how to do this.
So these are the different
stages of the playbook.
So first of all, it's
documenting the current state,
understanding exactly
what it is that you have.
The next thing is
outline the experiment.
And we'll come on to exactly
why we do an experiment.
Getting resources lined up--
you can't do this by yourself.
I mean, you can.
It might just be one of you, and
it's just your data warehouse,
but typically there
are many, many people
involved-- stakeholders,
end users, other teams.
So you know all those
resources need to be lined up.
How do we go about committing
and executing this?
And importantly, once we've
gone through this cycle,
showing the end users,
getting everyone excited
about the stuff, and then
repeating it for the next bit.
I guess you could call it some
kind of agile process, no?
AUDIENCE: Can you speak more
about how you might expand on--
ROBERT SAXBY: Yeah.
I'm going to go through
each of these stages now.
So to document
the current state,
I'll go briefly through this.
Why are we here?
What are we actually
trying to accomplish?
We're not just migrating
for the sake of migrating.
There should be
goals that we have
and we should be able
to articulate them.
Where are we coming from?
Get the white board out.
Get all the people
that are involved
from the different teams
actually explaining
where you're coming from.
Explain it to us.
Explain it to the
partner as well.
If we understand where
you're coming from,
why you have made
certain decisions,
we can take those learnings
into the migration,
into the new thing.
If we don't know
about those things,
and we is all of us in
this case, so the people
that are building this,
the partners, all of us.
If we don't know
about those things,
because someone
forgot to tell us,
then we're going to go
and discover those later.
And that will be somewhere down
the line after the migration
or during the
migration when data
doesn't look exactly the same.
And as someone will
say, well, actually, I
decided to do it
like this before.
So it's really important
to understand that stuff.
And find out-- get feedback
from everyone involved.
What's already working well?
Nobody likes having a new
solution put in place.
And they're saying,
hey, this is great,
but it works better over here.
You know, that's not the
place you want to be.
And what's not working well?
Because this will
also help you already
start to win hearts
and minds of people.
You say, well, this piece
isn't really working well.
So if we maybe
explore some of that,
we can already get
some people who
are standing around the water
cooler talking about, oh great,
we've actually
solved this problem
that we've had for a long time.
So outlining experiment.
This is really digging into
that piece of the documentation
and trying to
understand what it is.
What's the one piece that
we're going to take from--
let's say from all
the possible things
that we're going to go
and do for this first one,
this next one, what is
it we're trying to do?
So what's possible, what
are the constraints, what
is the value to the business?
In the initial use cases, as
I said this is an iteration,
but in those initial use cases,
think about smaller things.
Get some experience.
I know I just mentioned that
there's this problem that you
want to solve, but if you
can already get a quick win
and just get everyone's hands
accustomed to what you're
doing, that next
bigger problem's
going to already
seem a lot easier.
There are things that you should
be considering along the way.
You should be
asking us questions.
An example-- I once
got handed a project
which was all of
the ad data, and it
was a lot for the company I was
working with, being imported
on premise because
that's how they did it.
They didn't have the
processing power on premise,
so they uploaded
it into the cloud.
They ran a Hadoop
job on that data.
They then poured it
back and they put it
into the data warehouse, who
at that time was SQL Server.
We were migrating to BigQuery.
We had looked at this.
And we said, hang
on a second, do we
need to set up this ETL process?
And there was a data
transfer service available,
which put the data
straight into BigQuery.
Now, that's great if you're
working with [INAUDIBLE] GA
data or ad data, which is
already available for you
in that way.
That data might not be there.
But there are also, as
we mentioned before,
partners that are working
on this data as well.
So if you've got sources
which other people are using,
so our market data, Salesforce
data, all these things,
think about is are there already
solutions out there for that?
That's just keeping
everyone alert,
making sure that we
do useful things.
Define the time frame,
the requirements,
all this kind of stuff, and
sketch out an architecture
for the experiment.
And try to make sure
that everyone is aligned.
I realize some of this
really speaks to itself,
but sometimes just going
through it with everyone
is really useful in
getting everyone aligned.
Lining up the
resources-- so there
are a number of people
involved in this.
There's the customer.
There's a partner.
There's Google.
And there are others as well.
We may have analysts
in a specific domain.
We may have consultants
that have done this
before that we're bringing
in to work with us.
It's really important
to understand
who these people are, what role
they are, because another thing
that we see that happens
is we start a migration.
We're like, OK,
we've got this team.
They're going to do a migration.
And suddenly there's this
reason like, for example, we
don't have a partner in place
to actually help us and give us
the breadth that we need,
or we don't have one
of the data experts in place.
And we don't actually
understand the stuff
that we're now migrating.
And we started the migration,
and now we're like three weeks
and we've got a block and
that person is on holiday,
and now we have to wait, and,
you know, it's fun and games.
So making sure that we
understand the resources,
and who they are, and getting
them lined up timely for this
is really important as
well to be successful.
Commit and execute-- so there
are some things here you need
to think about-- security,
data locality, the cost,
licensing if you're--
there may be some
of the stuff you
want to use the third-party
stuff from partners
and you need to bring your
own license, for example.
So think about all
of these things.
And when you're about
to execute on this,
make sure that anything
that we execute on
addresses those concerns.
Otherwise, we go through
another iteration
with everyone kind of
standing around saying, hey,
but the security doesn't
live up to what it was.
The security is going
to be really good.
But we need to make sure
everyone understands
that the security is
going to be really good
and has had their chance
to explore that and get
information about it.
And the next thing-- you've
just delivered an MVP.
Show everyone.
Get everyone excited.
Let them see that it
solves their use case.
And then get the next one
lined up and reiterate.
And just keep doing this
until everything's migrated.
And you know, you'll be happy.
Your end users will be happy.
And you'll be asking for new
product features on BigQuery.
So that's it.
I'm going to leave you
actually on this slide, which
has some things for you to go
and get started, check out, try
out.
These are all small links so you
can just go and click on them.
There's about the date journey.
There's GCP free.
There's some architecture
stuff there as well.